my name is Tycho ytt I am the director
of Thor Ragnarok ultimately this film is
about Thor Ragnarok and his journey to
some outer space places people often
asked me why did you become a filmmaker
well the main reason just wanted
impressed my mum and dad and to show
them I'm a loser
I get what you stay I can achieve some
dreams not my own dreams but other
people's dreams I can get close to being
JJ Abrams I know you wanted him as a son
but you got me I'm sorry I'm not JJ
Abrams they say I wish we pulled you JJ
Abrams would have been so much cooler
you lived on Star Wars
well it didn't all right mom and dad I
didn't you stuck with me okay now down
to the nitty-gritty why did I make this
film for a kudos and followers on
Twitter what I really wanted to do with
Thor was capture the essence of Peter
Pan but a little bit of Terminator 2
a dash of independence day a smidgen of
on Golden Pond with a kind of tone of
beaches mixed in with my fair lady so
Arthur we've achieved that at the end of
the day when all said and done the
film's about two monsters some
explosions pretty ladies handsome men
there's a Hulk then it's the credits are
dead all the names were the people who
made it that's what we tried to do and I
think we did it that's what I wanted to
achieve with this film we're spit from
Taika Waititi from New Zealand
needless to get help no come on you love
it I hate it it's great works every time
humiliating do you have a better plan no
we're doing it we are not doing get help
Chris and I have been on this journey
together for seven years and it's very
different to any relationship I've ever
ever had with any other actor
we know each other so well and I think
in a way that enhances everything about
that relationship we have a shorthand
and he makes me laugh
it's just been this magical thing that
occurred this kind of really risky idea
bringing this whole world to life and I
think with Thor yet Hemsworth in front
and there was this very kind of little
sci-fi version of a Marvel picture can
each film he has grown a great affection
for earth and humans and the first time
we saw him when he was arrogant that can
be this great kind of strength and
knowledge and power with him but there's
also a sort of naive kind of kid there
at the center of it it's nice to have
that contrast and that mix biggest
concern is that their well-being of this
world and he very much is sort of
looking out further into the universe to
make sure that threat doesn't consume
this world as well
today we were working on kicks and
techniques and these things sort of
tricks and spins and stuff every day
there's something that's easier and
something that's harder we wanted to
find a style that feels different than
the way that you see most women fighting
and film in general I would say that she
fights like a boy except that diminishes
the fact that she just fights like a
really really strong woman Tess has
thrown herself at this in the most
extraordinary way just incredible
commitment to the physicality is of the
part the minute you open the door Wow
someone's got a history Tessa was so
compelling and powerful and mysterious
God we talked so much in Hollywood about
representation of women and we need
really strong
stand up parts or women but we also need
women that are in conflict and are not
so great
we need representation all across the
port he's now grown as a hero where he
can poke fun at himself where he can
become much more self-aware about his
surroundings we see a bar who's been
steeped in the world of Tony Stark he's
picked up sarcastic rhythms he's got a
sense of humor man is powerful and
useful to see though and he brings that
attitude into the stars with them and
it's that version of Thor that we're
elaborating on in our film to show Chris
as the comedic force that he really is
[Music]
Cole played by Michael ytt this
incredible actor it's so funny because
I'd kept saying on he'd play someone in
his film you know yeah we believe that
you can do it this parrot is extremely
fascinating to me he's a giant man made
of rock stone and granite
and opal who knows what's beyond that
there's a flesh-and-blood what he's got
a lot of courage that guy because it
takes a lot of hard work to build up
like that I thought what's good about me
hasn't been affected by his great
stardom and fame awesome I get pretty
bored doing the same thing and once it
feels too familiar or safe I think it
becomes less interesting
he's getting to do things in this movie
that he's never been able to do he's
recreating the character the male will
approach me they said we want to really
change up the franchise we want to take
fall in a new direction we want to have
an adventure and make it funny I will
tower over the mountains and bury my
sword deep in ass give it a second I
remember the first time reading the
script I did laughing out loud or not I
swear I'm not even moving the character
felt different
[Music]
Sekar is ruled by the Grandmaster played
by Jeff Goblin and he's insane and
colorful and hilarious I pardon you from
life
the Grandmaster is the photo negative of
Odin he's in very high status figure he
does things with disco grandmaster
improvises I'm practicing now this full
section which includes me as Grandmaster
playing with a band we wanted that
character to be really memorable and
Goldblum is just perfect I'm going back
to Asgard a scart I can't stand him all
that familiar he turned up Taiwan and
blue solo I asked place ass Berg eyes
God I'll tell you this and this is
honest it was as good a time as I've
ever had cabbie Jackie Chan yeah it was
really fun exciting and I liked what we
were doing
to have this villain s be introduced in
such a strong way is really exciting
I've had incredible fun playing with her
because I think her capabilities are so
surprising and so unusual she's not
simply sinister absent
as somebody who's played the villain in
these films I understand the
responsibility is that she has a huge
presence which she can express
physically or verbally she just has this
off-kilter movement to her character I
was completely blindsided by some of the
happiest times have been beating people
up something good you can't defeat me
shall we after you
[Applause]
four is back and you cut your hair looks
good on you oh you think I want to get a
closer look at this fused with
intergalactic extras that'll blow Wow
amen my name is cool what's this guy
again deleted scenes jack real
and an exclusive short team Darryl Oh
the Grandmaster was the only one who
answered my Craigslist ad for the most
fun you'll ever have at a Marvel movie
Marvel's Thor Ragnarok
you